[Music]
teresa is with us in morgantown west
virginia hi teresa how are you
hi dave i'm wonderful um i have a
question
um well first we owe like 33 000
approximately on our debt we're in baby
step two of course um
36 000 on our mortgage with five years
left um
my husband's 49 i'm 45. we did something
dumb
and we'll never do it again but um he my
husband took out 70
000 from his retirement 20 000 was for
state and federal taxes
so we put the 50 000 on debt um this
year
so he didn't have like the the penalty
thing
but still that was stupid we do have
approximately
um a million in retirement right now
um but he received a lot of overtime
that we didn't expect
um so he's already grossed over 130 000
so far this year and
my question is do we cause our debt
snowball and save all of our extra in
case we owe a lot of taxes because of
that
retirement i don't know if we took
enough out you know um
being put up in the higher tax bracket
so to speak um
you're guessing yes i'm guessing yeah i
just don't know
don't you just go to your tax person and
run your taxes now
run an estimate of what they're going to
be for 2020.
okay well we have like some farm things
that we do
and rentals and just a lot of different
so okay so
let your tax guy run you an estimate for
2020.
they did it they did your taxes last
year right they did yes
okay they'll be able to run 2020 with
these gyrations you've done
and then you can tell and look at your
that versus your withholding and see if
you've under withheld yep
okay um so then if we've under withheld
would i thought would i now you have a
new item at the top of your debt
snowball
okay called irs called the irs
and that's the same thing as putting
that snowball on hold and putting them
first right
but you don't want to screw with the kgb
i mean the irs you want these people out
of your life
right yeah but here's the thing i'm not
sure i'm not sure
that this is more than a vague worry
okay you have a wet finger you got no
math to back this up
no not too much i guess i just i just
don't want to be in debt anymore i want
to get out and stay out
yeah well tell your husband to quit
doing stupid butt stuff like cash not
retirement then
yes he he's already agreed not to do
that again
that's what's created there so the thing
is just
you know if you'll sit down and do some
detailed planning
then you can tell if your worry is a
real problem
or just a worry okay
yeah that's the sound of the cares act
that the government did
where they're allowing people to pull
from their retirement
without the 10 penalty but guess what
you do get to care about
is the tax burden because you have to
take care of it over the next two years
we don't we're going to change the
definition that karezak we don't care
about you
but you're gonna care when you cash this
crap out exactly right
you get to care there's the new cares
act definition but
i like that congress or we're here to
help yeah they're not and
and but i like your suggestion of going
to sit down don't speculate
let's know the villain whoever you're
dealing with what it is
so you can start the game plan and go
from there well i
how many times have i sat and i'm good
at math
and had the the those you know the
monster from the swamp in my mind
and then i find out it's a mouse you
know
and i thought dad gum man i just about
burned the house down
to kill a monster that wasn't even alive
a little bitty thing a little bitty
mouse
oh and so when you run the actual math
that is 42 dollars or something and i
thought it was 42 000
see and that's what fear does it it'll
it'll allow you to just isolate in your
head
and in your mind don't do that let's go
with the facts sit down with a
professional talk about it lay it out
and you know what you're dealing with